welcome to this video playing oke oke
from South Africa right yes the net 21
to get 11 flag right at least okay he's
probably going for this I was gambit
line c5 before and I never really felt
like battling that so I'm playing an
alternate an alternate an alternative
water if that's an expression that just
waits for white and Lady form okay
mistaking that's not not a bad line this
temperature it's uncommon but not
necessarily bad okay yeah well here i
have i have f6 as a possible line a i
also have from 97 to g6 not bad both of
them but i'll play f6 getting this
typical French move in it helps a lot in
terms of development
yeah I have pretty good peace
development okay so yeah I thought that
this might be might be an idea young
should I just castle or is there
anything anything better yeah I guess
castling is ok you know i mean this is a
slightly problematic pawn on d5 of
course it's isolated everything but on
the other hand of course i have a very
good f this bishop on d 7 is now really
participating Bishop g4 quite an
attractive move to play yeah i do that
why not yeah I wonder how can you play
this all instantly Bishop where 394
looks like and it's just good for black
I mean
and f2 is basically collapsing so I
wonder about this age 3 move yeah yeah
what do what I doing now about f2 I
wonder Kim maybe Bishop takes the form
sacrificing the Queen looks like the
relatively best option actually you move
the Queen i'll just take on f2 when this
is not not really ain't going to work
for a long time there's also Bishop f2
maybe queen age 5 is in in some way
playable but I wouldn't be surprised if
it if it's not working as well
yeah the ship f2 rook f2 is possible
hmm Wow ok probably rookie to win
I'm not sure about all this look f2 i
guess that's what i need to do really
Knight takes I'm made on 87 this is not
working Bishop takes he takes with the
rook night f2 was still made on edge son
so I'm not possible I guess it's that
one that I need to play now I'm
threatening look at five winning the
Queen and if he takes on f 2 i'm taking
with the bishop with the check and after
that he needs to go oh no he cannot come
to h 2 then this might be winning rook
takes Bishop takes King edge 193 wins
the Queen if it goes to h2 there is
Queen d6 check for example and slowly
needs to go to h 1 93 winning in the
Queen so you cannot really take on f2
now and if you cannot take on f2 the
threat of rook air-five check winning
the Queen should be pretty devastating
there's also roop takes f one with a
double check yes and this I need to take
Luke f7 check or its of seven check
actually on with it might be a some sort
of self pin but it should be a chubby
Aaron should be checked at least okay
and if I just take it the the easiest
way to play group 2595 and then I need I
give this a given check with the rook
but where exactly
hmm not really not really seeing a win
at the moment probably just being a
blind look f7 shake King h2 may be a
bishop d6 check out what's I have cream
v6 check
yeah I think that's yeah that's correct
actually okay now King edge 2 is the
only move I think and then I thought
bishop d6 check yeah why do I even
calculate stuff always some other move
going to be played like resigns yeah it
probably was I was a win in any case but
but I'm still reasonably irritated so
let's check that check this for a moment
yeah Bishop before is indeed the only
move to continue the game and this ruka
to is winning okay that sets a
reassuring 94 will get five check is
easy Bishop takes from a flap check as
well so this and after that i'm having
this check unless he goes there after
which this is mating okay so this was a
correct calculation the only thing kills
this and now let's okay i have i have a
very simple continuation check this one
okay what i can just take the bishop
next move that's very simple actually
okay important note what i did though
check this
this is not winning wow really King edge
2 is the draw at least according to the
computer I was thinking that Bishop be
six is good that's not even Jack
mentioned here I saw Bishop f4 but I
didn't really think it was working yeah
but what I what I overlooked is that
after this Queen takes Knight X the
night is actually here protecting the
rook and then there is a no advantage at
all amazing amazing I have thought that
we should wear for was not possible i
def if that's not possible black is
winning or in this check this i had seen
correctly but wow so this means so Luke
f7 was a huge mistake and I'm not really
sure why why took after 10 seconds or so
on c5 I mean you have 12 minutes and
it's obviously totally critical King
edge to seems to be a still okay what
else I can give a chest check like that
but then Bishop f4 is really is really
good for a while yes I had I was relying
on this move but Bishop f4 seems to be
okay if I take on c3 there is this jack
actually hmm not good so a huge blunder
here by me too to give this check on f7
just just this would have one very
easily wow oh wow check check
yeah and okay well he is just he is just
very easy can-can I took it but what can
change something like that but I mean
it's like queen for a queen for rook so
a very year very easy when alright
thanks for watching